well I think at its essence what
pornography is is it satisfies the
desire that people have for sexually
explicit content that you know is a very
strong human desire and people who do it
well understand it and know how to do it
I think what playboy aspired to from the
beginning was to represent the good life
and part of that was the attraction
between men and women and the romantic
part of life and that is also a very
strong human desire and one that is
shared by women and men and one that's
shared around the world so we see our
role as something quite different and
that influences the standards with which
we approach the content and the breadth
of content that we can deliver
appropriately under the Playboy brand
and in turn has allowed us to create a
real consumer products brand so I think
the lesson is to actually understand
what you believe your brand mission is
and then to be true to that in terms of
how the consumers see it and that's a
combination of your own standards and
some regular I think research into
whether the consumers are perceiving
your brand the way you want them to
which we do I don't know let's say about
every 10 years we did it just in this
last year with a company called red
Scout and that gives you that very
important sort of gut check from the
outside in